the Chevrolet bolt is the electric car
for the masses well okay the middle
class it's a surprisingly nice hatchback
and it's the first fully electric car
that costs around thirty thousand
dollars and can go 200 miles on a single
charge if the bolt is out to save the
environment then the Titan Warrior is
not it's supposed to be the ultimate
off-road truck powered by a five liter
turbo diesel v8 engine the warrior
hasn't upgraded suspension and a set of
massive 37 inch tires
it's probably a lot safer than a canyon
arrow minivans are not cool but the
Chrysler Pacifica is going to give it a
try anyway
it has a swanky rear seat entertainment
system and active safety technologies
and even though you can't see it here
there's a built-in vacuum cleaner pretty
sexy right anyway it's a plug-in hybrid
so it's got that going for it
which is nice okay you can't buy it or
ride in it even touch it
but outtie made this lunar rover for the
moon the automaker is sponsoring a team
of engineers competing to have it drive
around up there and send photos and
video back to us that is going to be one
super cool Instagram account what's the
most surprising thing about the Buick
Avista that it's a Buick the twin
turbocharged v6 engine in this concept
design will theoretically send 400
horsepower to the rear wheels
that is if Buick actually ever built it
we hope they do